uh well in a little while we are going
to be talking to the snp leader and the
first minister of scotland nicola
sturgeon but what are the nationalist
calls in wales we can talk now
to the leader of blood cumbria who is
adam price joins us now uh thank you
very much for being with us um
what are you hoping for in the local
elections uh next week it's been a
tricky few years for podcary hasn't it
uh well we're hoping to build on the uh
success that we've seen in the local
government uh with with mike henry also
uh gaining uh um uh
counselors in every part of where's my
camry means the party of whales we want
to be the party of the whole of wales we
have a strong base uh in the former coal
field areas of the valleys and also
in the western uh
half of wales but we want to see
that success actually flowing into
urban areas in the east of wales as
well as well as increasing the number of
councils on which we have a majority but
we lead four councils at the moment uh
but only one of them we have a majority
we'd like to see that uh uh grow further
this election and also what's what's
most important what is politics all
about it's actually using the the higher
number of councillors and the high
number of councils to make a difference
in people's lives so uh for example in
commandancio where i'm from we've uh
building uh
set to build almost a thousand council
houses now at a rate that we haven't
seen
uh in terms of council house building
program since the 1970s that's the way
that we can respond positively and
constructively to the cost of living in
emergency we're seeing rent increasing
at over 10 percent a year in wales one
of the highest rates of increase
anywhere in the uk and on house price
rises as well str uh outstripping local
people's ability to get uh their uh on
that uh housing ladder the way that we
can respond to that is at local
government level building council houses
so that people have the option to stay
in their communities uh with affordable
rent
okay are you talking there about the
desire to try and do better in some of
those urban areas in cardiff for example
you've actually formed an alliance there
of plaid comrade the greens and also
community campaigners standing under one
name the common ground alliance now of
course at the uh close of the last
council of elections in cardiff applied
to come we didn't have any counsellors
at all
are these alliances frankly the only way
you can get elected in some of these
areas
i i would say more positively sophie
because i i think and the response by
the way on the doorstep in cardiff has
been very very positive because people
people like cooperative politics uh they
look at you know what's going on at
westminster at the moment people are
looking for an alternative and they like
the idea of political parties uh even
though they may disagree in some areas
actually saying look
where we can work together for the
common good and find common ground and
surely that's a positive thing because
politics should be a about ultimately
trying to make a positive difference in
people's lives similarly at the national
level as you know sophie uh even though
we remain an opposition party in in the
senate we don't agree with the welsh
labor government and many things but
we've been we've shown a maturity you
know in the way that we do politics here
in wales by saying look just because we
don't dis we don't agree on everything
doesn't mean that we can't agree on some
things and therefore make a difference
uh to people's lives particularly at
this time of the cost of living
emergency so for example we're
introducing universal free school meals
for all children at primary school level
why because we we have
tremendous problem with child hunger in
wales and child poverty incredible when
we you know quarter away through the
21st century isn't it we'd like to go
further in plant company what we've said
in the these local elections where we uh
form a majority on the council we will
start
taking the steps to move forward to
introduce universal free school meals at
secondary level as well so that we can
really make a difference to so many
children in wales that are sadly uh
facing poverty at the moment
okay and just finally you visited
ukraine earlier this year so you saw
firsthand
uh the damage that putin's war has done
to that country
do you still want to leave nato and
scrap trident
an anti-nuclear party uh that's
absolutely uh essential uh i think in a
world nowhere as uh i think khrushchev's
granddaughter was saying uh uh only
yesterday we are closer to the
possibility of nuclear war than we've
been for many many generations and so we
need to to
ban those weapons of mass destruction in
the same way that we've done with
chemical and biological weapons but the
absolute priority at this point sophie
must be showing a practical solidarity
with the people of ukraine and what does
that mean that means a full economic
embargo which still isn't in place
you know we've got to get that full
economic embargo against the russian
estate and we have to uh i i think show
um a level of international leadership
that's been sadly lacking the un i think
has been
absent for a large part of this conflict
it was good to see the secretary general
uh uh visiting kiev recently we'd like
to see uh the motion at the u.n general
assembly creating a un peacekeeping
mission as a means by which the
international community
can show practical uh means of
demonstrating solidarity with the people
we're out of time now thank you very
much adam price